I guess let's start simple. Uh who who's
familiar with an LLM?
Okay, so everyone. Um who's who's
familiar with the concept of prefill
phase and a decode phase in uh LLM
inference?
>> Yeah. Um who's used who's run a model
locally?
Okay. Wow, that's good. Uh I I always
say like we're very early, but this
makes me think maybe I mean literally
all of you raise your hands, so maybe
we're further along the adoption curve
than I think. Um and
uh yeah, this is a a scary one. Who's
used Exo before?
Okay, couple. Uh cool. Um
so yeah, I guess um just a little bit of
background on myself. So, I'm the uh I
so I work on Exo. Um
we're a uh lab focused on running
Frontier AI on local hardware. So, what
we're doing is we're looking at
uh full stack what's involved in running
inference locally and uh working across
the whole stack. So, on the models,
software, the hardware side as well. And
um our mission is to drive down the cost
of running Frontier AI systems locally.
Um
so current state of things is like most
AI runs in the cloud. Um
typically if you know I guess this group
a lot of you have used local AI before
but typically if you're going to use a
model uh most people are using you know
uh models that are running in data
centers. Um
so why is that a problem and why why
should we even care? Um well
uh
I guess
The name exo actually comes from exoc.
So this is the idea that you know AI
will go beyond just being this tool that
you use for a chat interface which
already is and it's more of kind of
extension of yourself. And if you think
of it like that it's almost like a part
of you and a part of your brain and then
you ask the question well
do I actually want to rent my brain? And
I think Andrew Copathy uh has like a
nice oneliner that really summarizes
well which is like not your weights not
your brain. Um, and you know there's
there's
something
uh quite deep about that statement I
think and I think we're now starting to
realize you know as things like open
core you know and agentic systems are
getting more popular and it's more than
just a chat interface that
the
um
there's a lot
concern about,
you know, where is this thing running,
where is my data going? Um, you know,
what if it gets cut off, right? It's
like, you know, I had I had a friend
that works in cyber security and uh he
was doing some, you know, penetration
testing, which is uh uh pretty innocent
uh you know uh doing it for securing a
system and basically got locked out of
like three of the um API providers uh
like Claude, Gemini, and uh and chatb
um you know there's this is becoming
more than just you know this this uh
this chat right it's like you know you
need it to basically
be competitive in any field now and
there's uh
you know with centralized systems you
have uh you're relying on a few
organizations basically for this and um
I think you know there's kind of This
there's two realities, right? One is
where we have this closed source world
and in that world there's going to be
this massive power law where there's a
few companies that basically have the
most capable models and what they'll do
is I mean they will rentsek on on that
because you know that's how they make
the most money and uh you know what we
believe is there needs to be kind of a
competing force of you know keeping
things open and actually being able to
run these models without needing massive
data and it's a massive amount of
compute.
Um
so
I just want to talk a little bit about
sort of you know the actual technical
side of what we're doing. So um I guess
the first uh the first thing to realize
here is like a lot of the discussion is
kind of around training or has been
around training and um you know that's
um been
a lot of the focus of for example like
open source efforts has been in like
okay we need to have like um you know
transparency around training and uh what
I'm talking about here is like
specifically inference. So like if you
already have the model, you know, how do
you run that model? And uh if the only
option is to buy a million dollars of
hardware to run like Frontier model,
then that's like a massive barrier. And
um that's kind of what we're focused on
here. And um
like in terms of the hardware because
the focus has mainly been on training um
what
uh you tend to see is that
there's this idea of the hardware
lottery which is you know the research
that's out there isn't actually um
you know the best possible thing that
you can do. Uh there's a lot of research
that's being done on the current
hardware stack which is primarily been
built around training and uh what that
looks like is basically these NVIDIA
GPUs uh that you stack up in the data
center. Um but that's not necessarily
the you know the best thing to do
especially then when you look at
inference. So um you know the the the
current uh the current hardware is very
much focused on like you know flops and
flops unit economics and uh you know
there's this I really recommend like
giving this a read uh from Sarah Hooker
who was um she was at Google brain and
and then cohhere now I think she's doing
her own thing but um basically the idea
is like there's all these ideas out
there that haven't really been explored
because we just have a lot of inertia
behind the current way of doing things
with the current hardware. So our thesis
is you know there's all these things
that haven't really been explored uh
with different hardware and in the
context of inference that you know can
really um be a lot better than the
current way of doing things.
And uh this is really an area that's
super
uh there's a lot of like lowhanging
fruit out there. So like you know with a
little bit of um like I'll give you an
example. So like the other week we were
just looking at quen 3.5 and running
that locally on Apple silicon and we
found that like if you look at the
theoretical
uh speed that you would get running this
it's like way off what you get in
practice. And uh it was off by like 50%.
So like 50% slower than what we thought
it should be. So we looked into like
what it's doing and we found like
basically there's like bunch of overhead
that is introduced by inefficient
kernels and specifically like having a
lot of unnecessary kernels that kind of
get launched separately which leads to a
lot of uh overhead when you're running
inference. And you know each one of
these um kernels adds you know quite a
significant amount of overhead. If
you're thinking about running a model
like uh quen 3.5 locally you know
theoretically you might be able to get
like 150 tokens per second um which is
you know a token every less than 10
milliseconds. So if you've got like a
few milliseconds delay here and there
it's like it adds up to a lot. And so
what we did is we just did a little bit
of work on sort of looking at okay
what's going on and we realized you know
there's all these separate um kernels
being launched that are unnecessary. So
we just did some pretty basic work to
fuse that all together and increase the
inference performance by 30%. So,
um it's just an example of like, you
know, there's a lot of stuff out there
that maybe you would think is optimized
and you would think is already
um pretty close to, you know, getting
the best utilization out of the
hardware, but it's just not the case.
And um you know, this this exists across
the whole stack. So that's on the kernel
level but there's also a lot of stuff
you know in the orchestration
um in terms of you know how you connect
different pieces of hardware
um you know communication overhead
uh even stuff like the harness right so
like
um I think what people are starting to
realize is actually there's a lot of
value in the harness and
um you know for example if you use
clawed code with a certain model um and
then use open code with exactly the same
model, you get completely different
performance. And um you know this is
specifically interesting in the context
of local because you're super resource
constrainted. So
anything you can do
on the harness layer that kind of is
aware of the hardware, you'll be able to
get a lot of gains there. So it's just
across the whole stack. Um
so
broadly speaking like I said training is
about flops right so that's basically
everything is computebound and what
matters then at scale is basically how
cheaply can you get flops and you know
how much energy is you going to use um
but inference is mostly about memory so
um you know basically everything all the
operations you're doing depending on the
model is like most of those operations
are memory bound
And specifically like when you're
running stuff locally, if you're running
something for yourself, you don't have
the kind of um you you don't have the
ability to batch together, you know,
multiple users requests. So everything
you do is kind of uh low batch size,
which is merry bound. Why is that? Well,
yeah, basically uh this is kind of how
uh inference looks broadly speaking with
most models today. So there's kind of
like a pre-fill stage and a decode
stage. And my argument is prefill
doesn't actually matter that much um
especially when you're running stuff
locally. And uh the reason is basically
okay. So just explain like prefill stage
is uh loading your context with your
prompt. So you know if you're loading in
a PDF or something it's um the part that
actually uh generates all your KV caches
and then you have the decode stage which
is auto reggressive and that uh just
generates token one by one that part's
memory bound prefill part is compute
bound with the with the prefill part. Um
what you're seeing actually is like and
again this goes back to this idea of
like you know the harness matters a lot.
Um, so a good harness what it will do is
it would get a lot of cache hits. So it
would keep the prompt mainly the same.
And if you look at if you type in a
/context when you run claude code, you
can actually just see this. So you can
see that um, you know, it will basically
show you like uh all the parts of the
prompt. And you can see there's like a
big part of it that is just the system
prompt and system tools and that stuff
doesn't really change. So maybe if
Claude, you know, maybe if they push an
update, this will change. Uh but broadly
speaking, you can you know keep most of
the prompt the same uh when you're
running you know actual workloads end to
end. You know maybe in the benchmarks
you'll see people that are doing stuff
at like you know really long context uh
really long prompt sizes and you know my
my argument here is it doesn't matter
actually as much as people think. Um so
you know really um it's about decode and
uh what matters for decode? Well, it's
three things. So, like I said, it's
memory bound. Uh, but you know, the
first thing you'd have to actually fit
it into memory. So,
um, if you want to run a model at a good
speed, then if it doesn't fit into
memory, you're going to be loading it
from disk, which is super slow. Uh, so
that's like the first like hard
requirement basically. Uh, second is
memory bandwidth. So, this tells you how
fast it's going to run. So how fast can
you actually load you know your model
weights load your KV KV caches into GPU.
Um and the third thing and this is
something that
um is particularly like important
locally is uh the energy. So like you
know um here I'm talking about energy
per bytes. I'm talking about like in
these memory bound in this memory bound
decode phase like how much energy does
it cost to move one bite one gigabyte.
Um, and that tells you basically if I'm
going to run an inference, like how much
power is it going to consume.
Um,
yeah, this matters a lot. I mean, I
don't know like um there's a lot of
these kind of demos of doing stuff on
phones uh that you see on Twitter and um
we did a lot of stuff with phones, you
know, a while ago, maybe 18 months ago.
Um
but we found like
there's
a big issue which is energy uh and you
know the batteries on on phones are
quite limited. So you know maybe you're
talking about 10 to 15 watt hours uh on
like an iPhone and uh inference you know
it might be consuming something like 10
to 15 watts right so then you're talking
about like one hour of battery life
which is uh not really usable. So of
course um you know there's a lot of work
being done to improve that and I think
phones eventually we'll be able to run
you know better models on phones but
right now it's just like you know it
consumes a lot of power and it also gets
really hot. So actually when we were
running benchmarks
um like 18 months ago or so like the
phone was getting so hot um that I
couldn't hold it. It was actually like
too hot to uh to hold. Um
so yeah these are the the three this is
what these like actually map to in
practice. Um
and uh on the so like there's this uh
paper that's pretty recent um and uh
it's from a group in Stanford uh Hazy
Research maybe uh some of you know them
from their other work like uh Thunder
Kittens and stuff. Um but like now they
actually have a group that's focused on
this concept of intelligence per what.
And the idea is this kind of encompasses
these three things and it's uh a way of
like tracking like how are these things
improving over time. And the metric is
um you basically look at like how good
is a model at a specific task. You
divide that by the energy that it uses.
And if you track this metric uh you see
that you know this is actually improving
um exponentially. So over the past 2
years, uh it's been about 5x. Um the
correct term for this actually shouldn't
be intelligence per watt, should be
intelligence per jewel really because
you're not really um
concerned so much about the time here.
You concerned about okay for a given
task, you know, how much energy is that
going to consume? Um
yeah
so yeah this is uh this is now looking
at uh sort of memory improvement. So
this is actually like I mean the fact
that you can buy a commodity piece of
hardware like this that has I mean Apple
got rid of the 512 GB option recently.
You can't buy five these are 512s. Uh
but uh you know you can buy a 256 GB and
it's like you know you can buy off the
shelf basically. Um
so you know this this is like kind of a
very new thing like you wouldn't you
weren't able to buy consumer hardware
that had this much memory in it. Um so
this is like improving dramatically and
you know uh yeah give you example as
well like the new MacBook M5
um Max has 120 like you can get it up to
128 GB and the memory bandwidth is
pretty pretty damn good um 614.
So
yeah, this is kind of uh looking now at
the intelligence for jeweled. Um
so
uh
yeah, so it's actually so the 5x from
the hardware improvements, then you've
got another 3x from uh model
improvements. And obviously these things
compound. So what you're seeing is that
um a lot of the
uh
improvements here are coming from you
know hardware right um and also uh the
model layer. So this again goes back to
the idea that you know it's it's kind of
about looking at the whole stack right
there's a lot of gains across the whole
stack and uh there's different things
you can do. Uh,
can I just ask where we are on the demo?
>> Screen.
>> Yeah, I need a screen.
>> Okay, maybe we can ask.
>> Yeah, because I want to show you this as
well, right? Uh, I don't I don't just
want to talk. Also, if anyone has any
questions or anything Yeah. You have a
question?
>> Yeah. So, just in terms of the current
side of things, where do you see this
going in real life? Like I'm trying to
tell my friends like think of this like
an appliance in your house. You're gonna
go spend money on fridge buy one of
these and they look at me like telling
me to spend on a box right where's this
headed in terms of like the consumer
appetite and do you know is it purely
just upstream supply chain issues or is
this profit centering
like
>> is Apple seeing as what sorry
>> like a new a new
what I heard about chain is that when
these are built, they're already funded.
So like they'll essentially get all the
commercial contracts in RAM and then
they'll price the
interesting change to bump the storage
and have kind of reasonable.
I see you as a buyer of a lot of this
hardware.
>> Yeah. Curious what your thoughts are
like
as a consumer.
>> Yeah. Um maybe I can just repeat the the
question for the for the mic. Uh but the
question is uh where do you see where do
you see like you know the hardware going
and you know are people actually going
to be spending $5,000 on some kind of
inference machine?
Um
so my thesis is there's you know like I
said um
you can look at certain metrics like
intelligence per watt right um
and what you're seeing is that
progress is exponential also for local
right and um you know right now today
you need something like this right if
you're going to run frontier models
Then basically your only option is okay
first of all
the bar is always moving because you
know maybe now the frontier open model
you know we have GLM 5.1 which I want to
show you as well uh that came out
yesterday and that's probably the
frontier model now for for open source
and if you want to run that it's a
trillion it's a trillion parameters
um and
natively
It's uh
it's F16 as well. So like um you're
talking about like 1.5 terabytes or
something, right? So you need to like
fit all of that into memory, right?
Going back to the first thing. Um and
for that you're talking about, you know,
let's assume that you still have the 512
GB Mac studios like these, then talking
about like $40,000 of hardware, right?
Um and even then it's not going to run
that fast, right? So like it's kind of
you know maybe going to run at something
like 20 tokens per second if you're
doing this kind of setup. Um that's not
acceptable for a lot of people like you
know I think people are used to a bit
more than that now with uh the cloud. So
maybe something like 50 tokens per
second is kind of what people are
accustomed to. Um so that's like the the
current state of things, right? But um
you know our our thesis is this stuff is
going to um there's 100x in there. So
like you know if you look at like all
these parts of the stack because they
compound um if you're making like
changes to the harness if you're making
changes to the the models if you're
making changes to like the kernels all
of this stuff together um there's still
you know like um 100x in terms of like
price to performance in there. So where
I think things are going is like quite
soon you will like I think within uh
within
let's say 18 months you'll be able to
spend $5,000 $5,000 and have close to
frontier level performance running quite
fast. Um
but it's going to take kind of this
codees right of like looking at things
across the whole ST. You already see
that happening in the data center. Uh so
you know um the Grock acquisition by
Nvidia you know you're seeing like more
specialization different chips for
different things and this idea of
extreme code design. So looking at
everything together and seeing like okay
how can we build this these things in a
way that uh you know gets the best
performance for like the end use case
right and I think things have
consolidated and like even though things
are moving quite fast it's like some
things that don't seem like they would
probably change like you know having
like uh agents seems to be you know the
the paradigm and it will be the paradigm
for a while Um, I don't really see that
changing. Uh, you know, you see like
massive, right? So, like that also seems
like that's kind of consolidating and
that's why Nvidia can actually now go
and say, "Okay, we're going to build
like specific hardware for this
architecture because, you know, they
know kind of more about how these end
use cases are going to work." And uh
yeah, so I would say like maybe now I
wouldn't actually recommend to like
friends to say like oh go spend $5,000
unless they want to experiment. Um but I
would say within you know definitely
within 2 years you you will actually
have some products on the market that
you can just say hey go buy this box and
instead of having all these
subscriptions or you know now if you
want to use open core you can't even use
that with you know the the opus API
right um so you basically going to be
spending probably I know people who are
spending like $1,000 a day on uh tokens
at the moment right so instead of that
um you know just say like buy this
hardware and uh you know you never have
to pay for a token again. Uh it's
basically free right it's just the
electricity cost uh so yeah I I would
say in two years yeah
>> question
I guess
>> yeah as an estimate I mean
like like
you know these models are getting bigger
and better also like they're getting
smarter and smaller at the same time
some people are trying to make smaller
and smaller models
bigger models
and there's also like price of energy
going up but people are trying to also
price
build a lot more. So where do you see
all these macro figure out which of
these macro shift is going to win as it
were like driving to hear your
perspective on whether we're still going
to be like having models still cost like
thousands and thousands of dollars to
run each whatever it is like or whether
or not it's all going to shrink down
cost of hardware
great hard all these models
are always going to be larger and large.
>> Yeah.
>> So the the question is like more about
the macro of like you know where the
models are headed and and uh you know
you you have like a lot of progress in
making these models bigger. So like the
rumor with myth mythos is like 10
trillion parameters. I think that's the
rumor like 10 trillion parameters. So
like um and then you also had rumors
about Gemini being something like 4
trillion parameters. So like and then
maybe the next model run is like 20
trillion or something. So like you know
you're seeing that the models are
getting bigger. At the same time Gemma 4
just came out which is like tiny and it
seems to be better than let's say the
the best model from two years ago,
right? So like you know where are things
headed? Um, I think it's all of all of
the above. Like I think there's there's
going to be like a well there already is
and there's going to increasingly be a
massive demand for compute and there's
always going to be like a lot of
progress being made in the data center
to just you know pack more compute and
um I think what you'll see
at some point is maybe things will
bifocate. So like there'll be like all
these things that you can run locally
and uh you can maybe do like 99% of
things locally because if you look at
like different use cases all these use
cases kind of follow um an S-curve where
like if you look at how intelligence is
is is changing then at a certain point
there's massive diminishing returns on
running a more intelligent model for a
certain use case. For example, I don't
know if any of has anyone used whisper
flow? Yeah. So like as as far as I
understand like with whisper flow
there's like a little bit of
intelligence there to do like good
transcription and um to me like
having like a 10 trillion parameter
model go first of all like having a 10
trillion parameter go reason for a few
minutes wouldn't work in that use case
because you need it to be low latency
but secondly I don't think there's
actually much of a return there on the
utility that you're getting as a user.
um there seems to be like a threshold at
which okay if you have enough
intelligence the transcription is good
enough and I think every use case will
kind of follow this right and you can
point to like loads of other things that
are already kind of like this uh so
summarization for example um or you know
something like uh creating a to-do list
or you know summarizing emails like
simple things like that it's like do I
really need this massive model like no I
think there's like massive diminishing
returns. So that's going to happen and
then you'll have a point where okay,
there's still use cases where you just
do need a lot of compute. For example,
if we're going to like cure diseases or
whatever, then obviously, you know,
you're going to want like a really
intelligent model and spend a lot of
compute on that. But um most things that
like especially consumers use, they
won't need it. Um and uh that's where I
think most things will be able to run
locally. So that's where then you have
these two cases, right? Like either you
need to spend like a load of compute and
you need like billions of dollars of
compute to do, you know, this insanely
complex thing or you know you can just
run things locally. Uh that's my thesis.
Um I think it's hard to like the the I
guess uh one of the thing that uh
Copathy said recently is like the fog of
war is closer and closer uh getting
closer and closer. like it's more
there's more and more uncertainty like
for me I've been quite surprised a few
times over the last 2 years for example
I think the biggest like inflection
point for me was uh you know the
adoption of cloud code and opus 4.5 and
you know a lot of people uh
came uh you know uh back to work after
like the Christmas and used these latest
models and they're like holy [\h__\h] like
things have really improved and that was
the case for me at least. It was around
Christmas time when I was, you know,
that was the first time actually I used
uh clawed code. Uh and then, you know, I
was still kind of skeptical at that
point that it would be able to do a lot
of the work that we were doing, but then
it seemed like, oh, the frontier has
moved quite a lot. There's a lot of
stuff that just wasn't possible before
with with the older models, and now it's
suddenly possible. And a lot of that was
also the work on the harness and stuff
like that. Um so
no
there is just a lot of uncertainty here
as well like uh I mean who who knows
like the next generation of the models
what they're going to be like. Um but I
think generally speaking though this
will be true that you know there's not
kind of just unlimited returns on
intelligence right there's a certain
point where you just don't need any more
intelligence to do something and uh if
that continues to be the case then it
doesn't really matter where things go um
you know as long as the kind of progress
continues then you'll just be able to do
more and more stuff locally.
Yeah,
>> that's what you're saying is that we'll
get to this point where local models,
smart enough
models
on a Macintosh
and that's what pushes the curve at that
point.
I'm interested in another factor
Everything's very new at the moment. So
we haven't seen a lot of like model
ownership come through I think at a
level that really meets people's
needs for but I think as we like
as we have open models that are smart
enough
I think potentially
alternative
in a world where maybe the cycle of
obsolesence like down a little bit
better use out of that is that
is that a an interesting hypothesis or
is it guided in some way?
>> So
what is the hypothesis? So the
hypothesis is that
>> perhaps like
everything's changing so quickly now
that we don't have time to make good
model on a chip you know everybody's
moved on to say like the next hotness
already. You are you talking about like
specialized chips for specific models?
>> Yeah. So like three or so.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh yeah. Um okay. So the question is
about uh
things are changing really fast right
now but maybe if things kind of slow
down a little bit or stabilize and
consolidate then the best uh thing is
actually to have specialized ships
>> potentially. Yeah. That's the
>> thesis.
>> Uh yeah, it's a really good question. Um
>> like Talos.
>> Yeah, like Talos for example. I mean
Talis is on the extreme end of like you
know literally hardware built
specifically for a certain model. Then
you have I think you have a spectrum,
right? like you have GPGPUs like general
purpose GPUs like Nvidia uh RTX or
something or H100 right which is like it
was meant to do you know be this
platform that you can basically do
everything and then on the other end you
have Talos and then in between you've
maybe got like Cerebra Scrock um you
know I think for now at least it didn't
really make sense to um build these
specialized ships for LLM because they
are changing so quick so the frontier is
constantly moving but it is really
interesting I Think if you then start to
think okay well if you are going to hit
diminishing returns on a lot of these
use cases and you have a model that's
kind of good enough then maybe it at
that point you kind of have to look at
like what is the cost of building that
versus the savings that you'll get um
using that hardware and deploying at
scale. Um like the math didn't really
make sense at the moment cuz maybe the
frontier moves every 3 months. So like
okay by the time you built the chip it's
useless right. Um
but uh I think that will change. Yeah.
So I think you know we're not we're not
really like a we're not building our own
hardware like we are doing a lot of work
to like figure out what the best
hardware is to use but um at some point
you know maybe it would make sense to
start doing that or like work with
someone who is building the hardware
because
yeah like especially if you're kind of
co-designing the whole stack you can be
very opinionated about the models. So it
might even be the case that okay today
there's if you look at the
closed labs right they have to provide
an API that's quite generic because
there's all these use cases people are
using it for people are relying on it
for like all these different things
right and uh as a result they have to
have this big monolithic model that can
kind of do everything but you could
imagine if you're going to go be more
opinionated and maybe things do
consolidate and there's certain use
cases we know okay this is what we want,
then you could be more um kind of
strategic about specializing the models.
So you could say, for example, okay,
we're going to have 20 different models.
And these 20 models cover, you know,
pretty much the same things that this
big one one big model could do, but like
each one is specialized for a different
task. And uh maybe then what that looks
like if you then look at the hardware is
you would have a few chips that are
specialized, you know, can run those
models really efficiently.
Um yeah I think that is yeah that that
that that should um
that should be where things go right if
you assume that okay there is going to
be this um
uh things are going to flatten right and
there's you know for a consumer you can
do 99% of things locally then I think
that thesis will probably play out Um,
yeah. I I I
uh I think it's a really good point.
Yeah.
Cool. Yeah. I mean, I like this. I think
this is better than just talking.
>> Yeah. I think question on the hardware
side.
>> Yeah.
>> Because um you compare the NVIDIA GPUs
versus the Apple's metal hardware.
>> Um compared to
>> compared to the Apple's hardware
architecture. So if you load the big
model into obviously they have big
memory but if you load the model they
can fit into it but when you actually
run the inference the hardware get like
degraded so so quickly like you can't
get that much even if you have like 128
GB MAC compared with 5090 RDX you can
get way better inference on that Nvidia
hardware compared to our hardware. Did
you feel something like that? Yeah, the
question is uh
you you can fit stuff into memory on a
Mac, but it's slow. So like when you run
things on RTX, it's much faster. So did
you see
this? And uh what do you think about
that? So
yes, uh
I agree with you completely like um
these
These things are very different, right,
in how they're designed. So the Mac is
kind of unified memory. It's a big pool
of memory and it's maybe not as fast in
terms of memory bandwidth. Doesn't
really have that much compute. Then you
have the RTX, let's say RTX 5090, you're
talking about, if you compare that to a
MacBook, it has way less memory, right?
32 GB of VRAM, but it's
much faster, right? So I think it's like
GDDR 7 which is
>> close to two terabytes per second uh
maybe like 1.5 terabytes per second
whereas a Mac you know you're talking
about maybe let's say this Mac Studio
right it's 512 GB so it's like more than
10 times the memory but it only has 800
GB per second memory bandwidth so about
half and it has about 10 times less
compute right so
you know
I I think um that's all true and uh my
thesis is basically you want both. Um so
um
I talked about these two separate phases
of inference, right? The prefill and the
decode. But uh you know like we tend to
like look at these models as just a
bunch of layers, right? that you know we
don't really go much deeper often
especially like if you're thinking about
you know running a model a lot of people
are just like oh well you know I just
need a certain amount of memory
bandwidth to run it at this speed or
whatever but like
um
there's a lot more going on under the
hood right like you know if you sort of
look at the architecture of these models
then there's a lot of things
happening there and my thesis is you
want to actually I mean this is already
happening in the data center but you
want to kind of run different parts of
the model on different devices. So
the
>> the reason I asked because I got this
one 120 gig
I got 120 billion model right here. If I
run this in for 15 minutes, this is
useless. It's so hot battery. Even if I
plug in battery like drain within 5
minutes, 10 minutes, it's useless. It's
like basically compared to if I run the
same inference on like RX 5090
>> I can get much more I can I cannot big
model obviously I can like 30 million
model but inference I get is amazing.
>> Um so that's why I asked question your
experience with this kind of Yeah. So
somewhere here and can can we show the
spark?
>> Yeah.
>> So like uh actually Nvidia doesn't
generally sell their own hardware,
right? Like they actually usually
partner with OEMs that then sell the
hardware to the end customer. But in the
case of the Spark, the the one you've
seen is probably the Nvidia one because
they made an exception there. They have
like a founders edition which is um it's
not this one. So this is ASUS one, but
it's the same thing basically. Um, and
uh, this costs about $4,000.
And uh,
one thing we did uh, recently is
um,
combine this with a Mac, right? So
basically this is just a very simple
thing you can do, right? So you can
basically run this has a lot more
compute. So you can run the prefill
phase of inference on here and then this
has more memory bandwidth. So you can
run decode there. Now uh with the RTX
it's like different because it actually
has more memory bandwidth right and more
compute but it's a much smaller pool of
memory. So but that's actually um kind
of fine. Um, so
without going into like too much
technical detail, like you can basically
get more granular and start splitting up
the model in different ways and you know
that's actually the most cost effective
thing to do. It's kind of crazy that you
have to do this at the moment like that
there isn't actually some hardware that
just has it all. Uh, but that that is
the case today, right? So we today like
the optimal thing to do if you want to
run models locally is actually to do
both. So you would have a Mac Mac Studio
or MacBook
>> and then preilling. So prefilling is
>> uh the other way around. So but but like
you know there's more that you can do as
well in terms of splitting up the model
and you know we're going to like release
some stuff soon which makes it really
easy to do this. So
imagine, you know, you can just plug in
an RTX directly into your Mac and get
like a 3x speed up, right, on running
large models. That's the kind of thing
that we're working on. And
um again, it's kind of analogous to
what's happening in the data center,
right? You've got like with Nvidia, you
got these Grock chips which are running
part of the inference and they're like
very very high memory bandwidth and then
you have like tons of them. you have
this massive pool of memory and you pair
that with Nvidia GPUs
>> and uh same thing's happening with
Cerebras is doing something like this as
well now with tranium AWS tranium chips
um there's uh
um yeah there's a lot of like
interesting work be done in data center
side but like we actually we think the
same thing will happen locally just like
the software isn't quite there and the
hardware is a bit awkward like the fact
that you have to stack these Macs like
this and connect them all with
Thunderbolt cables and stuff. It's like
>> bitwise
engineering side of it which basically
you probably don't need code or codings
because you can get any local open
source model GM and all this thing and
just manage to quit it and build your
own harness on top of it and then
whatever tools are needed on this thing
and then run all the things coding
agents and all this stuff but I think
the biggest blocker is like how can you
just reveal and things because you need
at least at least 120 plus
2.3 or
>> at the moment. Yeah. But like if you see
for example um with your RTX actually
you could try running Gemma 4 the dense
version right should should fit in you
might have to quantize it a bit but
should fit into memory but like there
that's also interesting right because
okay
you know maybe the current paradigm but
maybe it makes sense in some cases to
run dense models locally as well right
so and in the case of dense model if you
run that on a Mac that's going to be
slow because um Now okay this the ratio
of memory to memory bandwidth on the Mac
is very high so like whereas on the GPU
it's you know
a lot lower so um
basically uh it doesn't actually benefit
you too much to fit this whole model
into memory now anymore that's like very
sparse like if you want to run a dense
model you just want as fast you want
like a small bit of memory that can run
it really fast So,
uh, in that case actually, you know, the
best thing might be to just run it on
the RTX, right? So, like this kind of
depends where things go, but like I
think at the end of the day, you want to
you want both. You want both. Maybe even
like other things like maybe for
example, you know, you will have a
specialized chip or whatever. And maybe
we'll have maybe we'll have SRAMM
locally. It's uh at the moment it's like
it's well it's super expensive, right?
And it's also like the density is very
low of the memory. So you can only have
a little bit of it. But maybe that's
enough for a lot of use cases, right?
Maybe you can run a smaller model really
really fast. Um so like I just think
it's not so much like Mac versus Nvidia
or whatever. It's like at the moment at
least it's like okay actually you want
bits of bits and pieces of all these
things. Um and that's the way you get
the most um price to best price to
performance.
>> So can you give us just like one minute
on how do you achieve that today? Like
let's say I just have this like I have
infinite swarms of hardware around me.
>> Yeah.
>> Am I running?
>> Yeah. So, it's really awkward to do at
the moment if you were just like using
the existing tooling out there. Uh, but
that's kind of one of the problems that
Exo solves. So, Exo is just an app that
you can install on every device and it
runs in the background and it will
automatically discover any other devices
that are connected. Um, and it works in
a mesh network so you can connect things
however you want. And um basically the
software like Exo software figures out
the best way to distribute your model
depending on like what hardware you
have. So
that's our goal with with Exos to make
that really easy, right? And then you
know for us like having these
heterogeneous setups and stuff is you
know we can solve a real pain point
there because it is you know even
talking to people at Nvidia that have
tried doing this kind of stuff locally
it's like very awkward. Um, and uh,
it's you run into all sorts of
networking issues and stuff like that.
Like we want to make it like turnkey
basically. So you install this app,
that's it. Connect things however you
want. Uh, hopefully we can get a de demo
and I can show you how that actually
works.
>> Those are already. Okay. Yes. Good. So,
we have we have uh four Mac Studios. Um,
and I'll show a demo of how that works
exactly in in a second. Um,
but uh yeah, the the problem is like I'm
kind of like hesitant to say like, oh
yeah, just go get all your hardware and
do that because like I said, today
it's especially if you're just picking
random pieces of hardware, it's like
there's uh not much you can do. uh
especially like if the hardware is not
doesn't have GPU, right? So if you're
just taking like Raspberry Pies or
something, it's like you know you you
again I always see these demos on
Twitter of like oh look I combined these
Raspberry Pies and ran this big model
and then you know you look into the
details and probably they've like
quantized it heavily so it's not
actually that useful and you know it's
probably like really slow on the prefill
so like it's not like really usable. Um
but uh if you happen to have GPUs laying
around then I think you know you could
create a cluster and have something
quite capable.
So your philosophy versus I guess that's
that's the hand I' understand to me it
feels like the solution you're building
but in terms of exposing over
a
>> yeah like again like doing inference on
a phone I don't think is that that would
is many years out I would say um so yeah
Like as far as how that would be used,
yeah, you're going to use like so with
Excel, it runs um exposes a HTTP like
just a API endpoint on each device that
you run it on and then you know you can
use something like tail scale like we
use tail scale um to access that
remotely
um they solve that problem really well
just like securely accessing your local
device and then you know you can be
anywhere right? So I can be here and
then have my cluster at home and chat to
it with an app, right? Like whatever.
>> Uh
>> we're not we're not we're not bundling
with tail scale. Um
but
we might have um
our own kind of solution for this soon.
like um it's uh it depends like how much
of a pain point it is cuz I I I don't
think it's that hard to like set up your
especially if you're setting up your own
cluster and stuff like then having your
own tail scale isn't isn't that much but
like something that we we've
experimented with you know a while ago
and uh it might be something that we do
um
yeah but I do think this this is kind of
how how you how you make something like
this usable
right? Um, you know, you want to be able
to access it on the go. You want like
like what I imagine is you have your
cluster at home. Um, or maybe it's just
one box, right? And, uh, it has access
to all your data, right? And you can
securely access it from your phone
anywhere and it's running something like
openclaw, so you can just like tell it
things. I mean, you can do this today,
right? It's just expensive. Um, but you
know, if if you're talking about now
that setup where you can just have that,
you don't have to worry about, you know,
these privacy concerns of like where
your data is going. Um,
and you can pay like $5,000 for that,
you know. I think there's a pretty
there's a lot of people that would buy
that.
Cool. Uh, I think we can maybe try
>> demo.
Uh, is there anything else worth?
Yeah, I guess like one thing to keep in
mind here is like I mentioned it
earlier, but in the cloud you can batch.
So like in the clouds you've got like
you you might have like a million users
or millions of users using your model,
right? Which is the case with something
like Claude or OpenAI. And so you kind
of have the benefit of just like being
able to take all these requests and
efficiently schedule them, also known as
batching. Um this is kind of how it
works, right? So instead of doing
inference each inference sequentially,
you can do them kind of together and you
get these like really nice um economies
of scale. Uh you can't really do that
locally because you might be a single
user. Um
and uh yeah, this is kind of how it
works. You can basically climb up this
like as you increase the batch size, you
can climb up this um
this line which allows you to get better
utilization out of the hardware. Um and
uh especially with the data center GPUs,
this works really well. U but I would
argue actually doesn't matter. Um so
like
uh I think this is one interesting thing
before we go to demo to talk about is
just like
I have like three um reasons why I think
um this so like obviously if you can
batch your unit economics are going to
be way better in the cloud right which
is then okay like if your unit economics
are 100 times better in the cloud than
local well then local is always going to
be super expensive relative to what you
can do in the cloud right so that's kind
of the argument But I would say um
actually um you know there's going to be
some level of batching even if you're a
single user locally. So first thing is
like multi- aent. So uh I don't know why
this was partly in Chinese but uh this
is like Grock 420. I guess it's not in
beta anymore. Uh so it's actually out.
But basically uses four different
agents. I think even more now. I s I was
using it the other day and I saw like
you know it shows you like what the
agents are doing and it seemed like
there were more than four. Um but
basically you're actually running now as
a single user if you do one request
instead of it just being one pass
through the model it's like these agents
that are kind of you know collaborating
and they're all running together. So
uh if this is the the paradigm then you
actually you know you're not going to be
running stuff for batch size one maybe
you're running stuff for batch size
eight locally and you know with the the
kind of characteristics of the hardware
especially with something like a Mac
then you able to get really good
utilization at that kind of batch size.
Um second thing is uh test time scaling.
So actually the first thing is a form of
test time scaling. Um but I think
there's a lot of interesting work being
done on more general approaches that
like are like search based approaches.
So a lot of the current AI I guess
paradigm is like about learning right.
Um so like how do you scale these
models, train them on loads of data but
there's actually another thing that not
many people are doing at the moment
which is like you know scaling um with
search and uh what I mean by search is
just like simple thing you can do is
like best of end so instead of running
one uh pass through the model you do
like 10 passes through the model and you
know have some way of picking the best
one and you can train a model that kind
of can basically verify these responses
and score them and then you you know you
can do more sophisticated forms of
search. So like there was a hugging face
I don't know if I have it here. Is this
it? Um yeah there was like some research
that came out of hugging face that um
basically showed that you can run a so I
believe this is a 1B model um and it's
looking at the accuracy of the 1B model
as you scale test time compute. So uh
with various different methods right and
basically what you see is like there
seems to be some scaling law here in
terms of you can run a smaller model and
do more test time compute more search
and get the same performance as a bigger
model. So you know maybe the next
paradigm will be something like this as
well and then again you can start to
batch right so instead of batch size one
it might be batch size eight or
something. Um the first the third one
which I think is uh really interesting
and I think it will probably hit an
inflection point maybe this year is
continual learning. So
this is the idea that instead of just
you know training your model up front
and then you know at inference time
you're just doing forward pass through
the model you're actually training the
model at inference time as well. So um
do I have something for this?
Yeah. So, so basically the idea here is
um what you might have is like everyone
actually has their own version of their
model weights based on how they use the
model and you know their own data and uh
you know this is kind of um there's this
whole area of like test time training um
where you know there's been a few papers
recently that basically have shown that
you can get
you've got like this long context
problem at the moment right or memory
where the models forget and like you
know you have to have these different
sessions because you have limits of
context and stuff like that. If you have
uh test time training you can solve a
lot of these problems because now
there's no such thing as context anymore
because you're literally like updating
the model weights as you're using the
model. Now this would completely break
cloud unit economics because now you
can't batch. So you wouldn't be able to
do this anymore because each model is
actually a different model. So, you
know, depending on how this lands
because there's scenarios we're here
where it might just be a small part of
the model that changes with test time
training, but on the extreme end, if the
whole model is changing, then you can't
batch at all. So, you know, that would
basically put, you know, local will get
like 10x better in terms of relative to
cloud if this happens.
Uh, anyway, I'm going to stop. I have
more slides, but I'm gonna stop there
and try and get a demo
>> if we're ready.
>> Ready for a demo?
>> Okay.
Any more questions in the meantime?
Yeah.
>> Just like what's your like general up
here?
Ah, this
>> I saw some
person.
>> Yeah.
>> No. Uh, so I I still use um at the
moment I still use a lot of like Opus
uh and you know um
yeah I use a lot of like Grock and stuff
like um I do use local for something. So
um and it's growing as well, right? So
like the set of use cases where again
it's like good enough is kind of growing
but I would say utilization is pretty
low
at the moment. So I guess uh to to
repeat your question so it was about
like utiliz uh util how much utilization
do you get out of the cluster and also
what about renting out that spare
compute.
>> So this is I think a really interesting
idea as well. It's not something we're
really focused on at the moment because
doesn't make sense if we don't have
scale. But if we have scale, let's say
we have a million exoclusters
then and everyone's kind of using it for
themselves, then the utilization might
be quite low. Uh in which case all this
spare compute, all this idle compute
that's just sitting out there. So why
can't we make use of that for something?
Maybe it could even be you know for like
a
uh a volunteer like science
kind of um problem for example right
where it's like okay well any spare
capacity I have it can go to like
solving this scientific problem um which
requires a lot of inference right I
think this is a really interesting idea
and it's something we'll revisit once we
actually have you know a scale um yeah I
think um there's There's a possibility
here as well where actually utilization
goes up a lot because even for your
local cluster without this because uh
imagine like you can actually get
frontier level performance locally right
well and you can just give access to all
your data like what I would personally
want is um I would just want this like
because I'm not paying for tokens I just
want this thing to run all the time and
like maybe it can like proactively you
know tell me about things it can be
scanning the internet um for things that
are relevant To me, it can constantly be
like, you know, it could be thinking
about, okay, future direction of EXO,
maybe things to look out for. Um, you
know, you basically have this like 24/7
agent that can be looking out for you
and as like a companion. I think that
would mean utilization goes up a lot,
right? And uh you would just want this
thing to be running all the time. So, in
that case, maybe there won't actually be
that much uh idle compute out there. Um
but uh I think it's interesting. Yeah.
Once we reach scale then we start to
think about these questions of oh
actually we have the equivalent of the
biggest data center biggest data center
in the world. it's just distributed
across the globe you know um is there
some way to make use of that and uh yeah
I think inference is quite easy actually
to do in this setting because you don't
really need much uh communication
happening between different machines um
especially if you know if people already
running these frontier models on their
hardware then they already have the
capability to run that right so you
don't need to do any kind of clustering
over the internet or anything like that
because they already have this
capability. So then it's just a matter
of distributing work uh in like kind of
data parallel way and that's really easy
to scale. So
>> yeah on that topic do you think there is
like some parallelity back when
everybody was mining like crypto at home
and was building their GPU racks because
then
>> more and more people started doing it
prices dropped. You could argue price
per token drop, right? So, it's not
worth it for lots of people.
>> Yeah.
>> My argument would be it's never going to
be worth it to rent out your hardware to
other people if you're just
>> Yeah.
>> want if you just want financial gains if
you're doing it nonprofit.
I I I think I'm mostly So the the
question was like uh do you think it
would be like crypto mining where
originally it was economical to run your
own GPUs and mine Ethereum for example.
Uh but then eventually you know you had
these large scale operations that made
it um just not worth it to mine
yourself. Um
yeah, I think like
um
>> there's again a few things here. So
>> mean some things are different, right?
Because
>> yeah,
>> running a local model, you have all the
benefits. Your data is not going to the
cloud. Crypto miners just run at 100%
all the time. It's not same incentive,
right? But there are some things that
seem quite similar in the first like
>> um
yeah, I I I think like that's why I I
said like it only makes sense once you
we reach scale because um I don't think
any project that just is its goal is to
you know
give you money for renting out your
compute is going to work. And I think
there's already been quite a few
failures, you know, especially like I
think a lot of the stuff out there right
now is kind of at the wrong level of
abstraction where you're renting out the
hardware whereas what you should be
renting out is the use case, right? So
like it should be you can go higher and
higher up up in the stack and you could
for example charge for tokens or you
could charge for like something even
higher level than that like a task,
right? And I think the higher level you
go, the more you can get creative with
how you make use of the hardware. And
for example, maybe it turns out that
okay, this compute that's out there um
people are willing to rent it out for
like very cheap, right? Um because uh
it's literally just spare capacity
that's sitting there, right? So they
wouldn't be getting anything for it
otherwise. In which case you know if you
can
you know if you can basically for
example build something that's higher
level that let's say is something like
uh
imagine an API where you can just submit
a task and it will get done in the next
24 hours right so it's not latency
sensitive doesn't necessar if it fails
can just be retried something like that
you could maybe have an API that's
really really cheap
>> that runs on this kind of network Um but
yeah I I think like the first thing is
first you need first of all you need
like people to have a lot of capable
hardware and I think local AI will be a
big catalyst for that and then you need
scale right there's no point doing this
on 100 max it's literally like
negligible amount of compute you know it
becomes interesting when you start to
you know look at like okay what if we
had a gigawatt of compute it's like well
you
How else are you going to get that
compute? There's a few companies that
have data centers that need all these,
you have to go through all this, you
know, have to raise so much money. You
have to have these permits and stuff
like this is like kind of a another way
to access like large amount of compute.
So, it could be interesting. Um, but
yeah, it's it's not really like
something that we're thinking too much
about until we reach scale.
Yeah, I think we're almost like we're
quite close to time. So, I want to show
the demo. Uh,
>> yeah.
>> Yeah. Is it ready?
>> I think
I have to SSH.
>> Uh, no. I know you can look at it on if
you're on
>> it. Should be
trying to set up
unless they're not.
>> No, it's working.
>> Okay, cool.
Cool.
>> So,
uh,
okay. So, yeah, we got four Macs here.
Um,
and they're all running Exo. So,
basically how that works is just a Mac
OS app that you run in the background on
each machine and they
um that's all you do. So like you just
install this app runs in the background
and what happens is they're connected by
Thunderbolt. So
uh I don't know if it's easy to show can
see it better if I turn it around I
guess.
So
basically um
each Mac is connected to each other Mac.
So they're connected with Thunderbolt 5,
which is
basically like it's kind of just like uh
a wrapper around uh PCIe. So it's like
pretty fast. And um we actually did some
work uh recently
um to integrate low latency RDMA into
Exo. So prior to that the latency
between Macs because this is just like
consumer hardware it's running this
bloated Mac OS uh it was really slow. So
you would get like 300 microsconds like
0.3 uh milliseconds of latency if you
wanted to send data between the Macs.
Now problem with that is um doesn't
really allow you to split workloads in a
efficient way where you can actually
scale up. So what you want to do if you
want to actually get a speed up is you
want to kind of distribute each layer
across um your machines. Um if you have
60 layers in a model, which is the case
with Kimmy or DeepSeek, then that's um
at least 60 times that you have to
synchronize every time you run one like
generate one token. So and it actually
in the case of tensor parallelism which
is uh a way of splitting up um you know
your uh tense operations across these
machines you have to do two
synchronizations per layer. So that's
120 synchronizations for a model like
Kimmy. If that's gonna let's say it
takes you know 0.3 milliseconds that's a
lot of time that's like 40 milliseconds
that spent just on uh the communication
right so that would be really limiting
in terms of the speed up that you get
and in fact prior like back then you
wouldn't even get a speed up. So by
clustering stuff like the benefit is you
have all this memory that you can split
the model across so you can fit bigger
models but it would be slower.
Um anyway, long uh long story short,
with RDMA, it's 100 times faster. So,
it's like singledigit microsconds, which
now instead of it being like, you know,
30 m uh 30 milliseconds of
communication, it's like less than 1
milliseconds, right? Which is perfectly
fine if you want to kind of scale up
these big models. So, GLM 5.1 just came
out yesterday.
>> Is it a trillion parameters? GM
1.
one point
>> uh wait
>> I think it's trillion parameters um and
uh yeah basically um
how the hell are you going to run a like
trillion parameter model
>> yeah try
>> yeah it's like massive um so
well the idea is uh you wouldn't be able
to run it on a single device just too
big so we're clustering across these
devices and in combination with this
RDMA capability can actually run it
faster faster than it would run on a
single device. So,
uh it's already loaded into memory. You
can see it here. So, GLM 5.1
>> and uh
>> Thank you so much.
>> Yeah, the way Exo works is you can spin
up these instances of models and an
instance is just um
one configuration of a model that's
running on your cluster. So
um
it's already loaded into memory and you
can see like the utilization on each the
memory utilization on each of the
machines is like 112 GB or something. So
this is this because of like it takes
like really long time to download these
models. We just downloaded the 4bit one
um which is still pretty big. It's like
what is it almost 400 GB? Um
but uh the full model here would be like
1.5 terabytes just you know uh
it literally came out yesterday. So we
just download the 4bit one but um
yeah I can just uh chat to the model. So
um does it know about
AI engineer? I'm curious.
>> Alex good question. Have we converted
into
Sorry,
>> have you converted this model to MLX?
>> Yeah. Yeah, we did that yesterday. So,
basically uh when a model comes out like
there's always this rush to like make it
compatible with the hardware. So, we did
uh Leo did that yesterday. Um downloaded
the model, converted it. Fortunately,
with this one, it was quite easy because
um basically
um GLM 5 was already out, right? So this
is just like another checkpoint of the
same model. So the architecture is
exactly the same. We already had support
for it. So with this we just had to
convert the weights. Didn't have to
normally if a new model comes out like
Gemma 4,
>> we had to do a lot of work to get that
working especially like Gemma 4 is quite
different in its architecture and that
um the way like the KV cache works is
very different like any other model. So
we that was a bit of a pain to get work
and it yeah anyway uh so yeah that did
it know about it first to a prominent
community
it's founded by Swix yeah I guess this
is recent checkpoint so it knows about
it knows all about this I don't know how
long AI engine has been around but um
yeah so this is running across these
four machines and if you uh
so if you look Nice. I don't know how
big. Can you see it? Well, like you can
see basically the utilization on all of
these machines is um is like uh it's
it's 100% on all of them because all of
the machines are being used in parallel.
So this is tensor parallelism with RDMA.
It's a little bit like you can see the
response is a bit choppy, but that's
because this is I think I'm connecting
over Wi-Fi, right?
>> So like it's actually just the
connection between my Mac and the
cluster. But here all I've done is like
this is running tail scale. So we have
um a uh machine that has a host name
James and uh you know just I'm just
basically connecting to that uh to the
dashboard over tail scale. Um
yeah that's uh I don't know if we can
maybe run a different one as well.
Depends what we have.
Uh
Let's try this one.
Quen 3.5 should be fine, right? I try.
>> Yeah.
>> So, like I said, you can um you can
basically have like different instances
uh of the of um of different models. Uh
and you can run these all together and
um this one is downloaded on a few of
them.
So
I can try this. So this will be a small
much smaller model. So it should run a
lot faster. Should be downloaded on
these. So if I launch that
um it will load the model into memory.
So you can see on the two machines that
it loaded on the memory went up a little
bit. So on Mike and S3 in the top and
the bottom ones, it's now like higher
and uh once it's loaded into memory, you
can just uh chat with it. Uh and it
should be, you know, much much faster
than the other one. So again, it's a bit
choppy because the Wi-Fi, but you know,
you can see the tokens per second is
like 77. Um
and um yeah uh
so like if I get it to do something a
bit longer, you can see basically the
utilization is going up on these two
machines because they're again working
in parallel. Um so yeah, it's it's
pretty simple. Um but like uh a lot of
the complexity is sort of in um just
like making it this one app that you can
install and you know not having to do
any of this network setup and it just
kind of figures out the best way to
shoot the model. I also want to show
>> uh setting up the network.
>> Okay. So yeah, I also want to show like
why we brought a spark like so there is
um
uh also the ability to split models
across heterogeneous hardware right so
you can take like spark and uh Mac and
uh in this case obviously like I said
before this has a lot more compute so
there's some interesting things we can
do in terms of splitting up the model in
you know more kind of um granular ways
than just like the way that we're doing
it here which
you know tens of parallel. Um,
cool. Well, while we wait for that, I
can go back to the talk. I mean, we have
15 minutes. So,
also if anyone wants to like try, we can
try this like if anyone wants to try if
they have Exo or want to install it,
it's like exolabs.net.
And we could try also then adding that
to the cluster. So, because it's like,
you know, super easy to um to add uh
devices. I'm not sure if it'll work over
the Wi-Fi because it depends on the
the uh firewall, but we can always
connect it with Thunderbolt. I think we
if we have another cable if someone
wants to try it.
>> You got it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So,
uh, okay. So,
>> is this running the app on new? Yeah, it
is running the app, right? Yeah,
>> like the latest one.
>> So, let's give this a try.
See if it works over Wi-Fi first. So
>> I got the same Wi-Fi as you probably
>> Yeah. So if I open the dashboard which
should
>> it's not working in Chrome.
>> So yeah the idea is like you can just
connect these in any way you want. So
it's like works with a mesh network. So
you know we should in theory be able to
just connect this MacBook and have it
join the cluster. Um,
yeah, it looks like isn't working over
Wi-Fi. Must be something with this
shared Wi-Fi, but we can try plug in.
>> Should be able to plug it in, right?
With
>> Yes.
>> Let's see.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, you don't have any models as well.
So, that might be We'll do a small one.
We'll do a small
>> uh
GPD.
Oh, you have it.
>> Gemma 4.
>> Yeah. Gemma 4.
>> I don't know if that will work because
on this version of the app,
>> um, we'll try it.
>> Yeah, it is.
>> So, one weird thing with this hardware
is you should never use this port next
to the Ethernet.
>> Um, we we don't really have a good
explanation for why, but it just doesn't
work. Um, apparently Apple is fixing it,
so
You can use any other port though
>> and all of them are so like you need
Thunderbolt 5 to do RDMA. What what
MacBook is this?
>> Do you know what chip it is?
>> M4.
>> M4. M4 Max. So this has this has
Thunderbolt 5.
>> Uh do you have RDMA enabled? Because you
have to you have to actually So
>> you can use the pipe library.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I just thought it'd be cool
if you can do RDMA.
Um,
so if we wait a bit, they should
discover each other automatically
hopefully.
Yeah, you have Exo Thunderbolt. So
should
Yeah. Okay, it's working. So you can see
like um actually the first thing that so
this is just like an architectural thing
about exo but the first thing that will
happen is when a new node connects it
basically catches up on the whole
history of what happened in the cluster
because we use uh
um event sourcing which is uh basically
like commonly used in distributed
databases as well like where each
machine basically writes its own uh
appendon log and then they kind of get
merged in some way. And the reason we do
this is because of um you know
consistency guarantees across the
cluster. So if you're working with
something that's quite dynamic like this
then devices can come in and out you
know uh basically whenever like a device
could power off like this could go to
sleep or whatever. If you're working
with that then how do you like guarantee
that if a request is going on it's not
just going to get lost right? So that's
kind of uh from the very start is like
how we architected this. Um
so it's just replaying that. Um but yeah
I guess I was talking about RDMA. So
this uh everything so like M3 Ultra
which is these M4 Pro, M4 Max, M5 Pro,
M5 Max all have Thunderbolt 5.
Thunderbolt 5 is required for RDMA. Um,
and
yeah, look, you can see it's literally
replaying all the stuff that we just
did. I don't know if it's hard to see,
but um, so,
uh, yeah, but the issue right now is
like you basically have to boot into
recovery mode in the Mac to enable it
because it's more of like a developer
focused feature and Apple is a consumer
company. So, uh, they don't want this
like on by default right now. Um, so
this one doesn't have it enabled, but
what we can do is like, you know, try
basically creating an instance uh just
over the TCP IP. So it' be slower, but
it should
uh it should be possible.
Uh yeah, it's got to point where we were
running the second model now. So it's
almost there.
I think it might There we go. Okay. So
now you can see like this has popped
into the cluster and you can see it's
only connected to this one um which is
this Thunderbolt connection. So Exo like
maintains a live view of the physical
topology and with that it can figure out
the best way to distribute the model
basically. So
oh okay we did get a warning here that
there's incompatible Mac OS version. So
this is on a different Mac OS but we can
still try. Um so sometimes you have it
looks like this on Mac OS 26.2
whereas these are on 26.3 and sometimes
that can be an issue but we can still um
we can still try it. So, you said you
had a model, right? We can look at what
you have. Uh,
wait, can I put this on the
>> Can I put this
work?
Does it have a HDMI this Mac? Uh, I
don't think it does, right?
>> Do we have an adapt? Do you have an
adapter? Okay, I'll show the dashboard
from this machine. I can still do that.
So, yeah, you can see now the MacBook is
there, but it says that there's
incompatible Mac OS versions because
this is on 26.2 whereas these are on
26.3. Uh, but actually I can do it from
here. So, I don't even need to do it
from there. So, that's nice thing as
well. I can access, you know, any of
these machines are running the same API
endpoint, the same dashboard. I can just
send requests to any of them. So, you
said you had a model. I don't see it
though. I don't see you. You don't have
any models.
>> I mean, it's fine. We can we can
download a model. We can just do a small
one.
>> So, so many models downloaded MLX and
LM Studio as well.
>> Oh, it's not
Ah, I see.
>> Ah, okay. So, you have it from using
MLX. Yes. So, that puts it in a
different directory.
>> Studio as well.
>> Um, it's fine though like what we can
do. So, you can filter here. So, you can
basically select any set of nodes and
then it will filter configurations by
those nodes. So, if I filter by ones
that contain the
uh wait,
is that filter working or whatever? That
that looks correct. So if I launch it
onto here,
see how it plays with the
with the different Mac OS version.
Hopefully it works. Oh, didn't like
that.
I don't think it like Oh, no, it is just
downloading. Okay, so when you launch a
model, obviously first it needs to be
downloaded. Um,
which is actually quite a big pain point
with this stuff. So if you're running
safely obviously you need to have the
entire model weights that's means you
know sometimes you need to download like
a terabyte um which yeah you just need
highsp speeded internet basically um and
obviously in in the case of like when
you're splitting the model across
machines as well like you basically need
pretty much the whole model weights on
each machine. you can maybe get smarter
with like putting parts of the model on
different machines. Um, but it's kind of
difficult because now if a node dies
then the part of the model that it's
responsible for will be different. So
you basically need the whole model on
every machine. Uh, so if this finishes
downloading,
we can
run an inference. So this is quen 0.6b
which is basically as small as it gets.
It's only like what is it? 0 point 0.3
gigabytes
shitty Wi-Fi I guess.
>> Can you see this existing model with XO?
>> You can use it but it's it would need to
so like right now you have to like
manually migrate the models over to Exo.
So if you have using a different app
like Llama CPP it won't be uh possible
to easily uh transfer it. We're going to
add actually that so that you can just
if you have models already from a
different app then it will just exo will
recognize it. But it's downloaded. So it
says it's ready.
Uh
so this should be running on the Mac.
Yeah. So you can see
let's do something longer.
Okay, maybe the utilization here is
broken, but uh yeah, basically this is
running on the the MacBook here. So
yeah, the idea is like I mean you get
the idea, right? You can basically just
like run this application on any of your
machines and connect it in any way you
want and then Exo will figure out the
rest. Uh
>> you have it
>> pre-filled your code. Okay. So next
thing I want to show you is like okay
what if it's not just Mac? So what if
you have different hardware? So I just
quickly show you like you have a Spark
here and you have a MacBook.
>> Do you want to connect that to the HDMI?
>> Yeah, sure. Uh which HDMI
>> it's this? Do you have HDMI port?
>> Okay.
But is it running? Like can we
>> try it or
>> Yeah. So the idea is run prefill on
there, run decode on the on the MacBook.
This thing has twice the memory
bandwidth. The MacBook has 546 GB per
second. This has 273 GB per second of
memory bandwidth. Whereas this has four
times more compute. Um so like the ratio
there difference in the ratio is like
12x. Um so the idea is basically
uh you run like for really large prompts
uh you get actually get a big speed up
by you know not just running on your
MacBook but also splitting it up across
here but you don't want to run the
decode on here because it's slower for
memory bandwidth. So basically uh yeah
you you split up these two phases and
then there's like some complexity to
like streaming your KV cache because now
the KV cache only exists on here. Um so
you need to somehow get it to the
MacBook so it can do its decode, right?
Because the KV cache reads it every time
it does a pass through the model. So the
way we do that is uh they're connected
by 10 GB Ethernet. I don't know if you
can see, but uh 10 gigabit Ethernet. The
MacBook doesn't actually have Ethernet
port. So, we use a 10 GB Ethernet
adapter and uh so it's a bit of an
annoying actually because ideally like
you can just have some USBC cable or
something connect them with that. We
don't have that working yet, but well,
we kind of have it working, but it's not
really like production ready because you
have to run a bunch of scripts to get
that working. Um
>> but uh
>> is the wife is it going over Wi-Fi?
>> Okay. Uh
is it should we skip that? Skip this.
>> Okay. You can try a little bit longer.
for maybe five minutes and then
uh yeah the issue is like um
for some reason it's sending the KV
cache over Wi-Fi at the moment which
then the bandwidth becomes a bottleneck.
So what you that's why we need 10 GB
Ethernet because you're sending this KV
cache over. You don't want that to like
uh block you know you being able to
compute the decode phase, right? So you
need to basically overlap computation
and communication and like stream the KV
cache over to the MacBook and it needs
to be fast enough so that you can fully
overlap. If it's not fast enough then
you would be sequential. So, you'd like
do a little prefo, then it will still be
sending, and then it would do the
decode, which is um which is going to be
slow. Uh can I have the HDMI back?
>> Yep.
>> Yeah, I guess we're almost well, we're
out of time, though. So, uh I will
close off with one thing, which is okay.
Like, I'm telling you all this stuff,
but why is this not already like kind of
more understood or more known? Well,
basically like the best source at the
moment for this stuff is like Reddit or
Twitter and everyone says different
things. So like you know I to I
mentioned before like you know there's
maybe a lot of threads that you see or
like people that run experiments. Now
you have all these citizen scientists as
well which I think is cool uh because
you know you have really capable AI
tools so people can quickly experiment
and try things but then the flip side of
that is like there's a lot of noise and
uh if you don't truly understand what's
going on then you might actually think
you have a result um and like the LLM is
telling you oh you've made a
breakthrough
um but actually it's you know it's it's
not so interesting and it's it's not
really usable. Good example of this is
like people heavily quantizing models.
So if you like quantize a model to one
bit, then you're better off just using a
smaller model and not quantizing it. Um
so it's not like these these models are
not very useful right at one bit. So uh
you might see some threads for example
about oh I ran Kimmy on a MacBook or
something but you know it's like the one
bit version and maybe they also pruned
it or like you know instead of it
activating eight experts of the model
it's activating two experts of the model
or something you know and like what we
want to do is actually like bring some
transparency around this. So we have
loads of hardware. Um
yeah, we we we we have probably the most
um like hardware specifically for this
purpose. Um and you know our idea is we
want to publish benchmarks in the open
that show you okay what performance will
I get on certain hardware and um this
stuff is changing really fast as well
right so like I said I think there's
100x you know in there so this will also
be a source to be able to track progress
right so you be able to see like okay
you know how is how are things getting
better is the software improving is the
hardware improving you know are the
models improving So this will be very
soon. Uh you know let's say within the
next month we'll come out with a website
that basically has thousands of
benchmarks on there. We're already
continuously we're getting the data now.
So we're continuously running these
benchmarks, different models, different
quantizations, different ways of pruning
the models. We also we want to pair this
not just with like raw performance of
like tokens per second and prefill time
but like also the quality of the model,
right? So for example, intelligence per
jewel, right, is one way of looking at
looking at that. Um, so basically you'll
be able to select the budget, let's say
$10,000 and see like pareto frontier of
all the local uh setups at that budget
and um it will show you like, you know,
if you want really good quality, you
might have to like compromise a bit on
the performance. So if you want like to
run GLM 5.1, then maybe you're going to
get 20 tokens per second. Um but maybe
you know for you it's fine to use a
smaller model in which case maybe use
Gemma and you get like a 100 tokens per
second and all of these kind of exist on
different points on this parto frontier.
Um so yeah I I guess I close with that.
Um, so unless we have this or
>> Okay.
Uh, yeah. Um, yeah. I I think I don't
know if I think we're basically at time,
so I'm not sure if we have any time for
more questions, but yeah, thank you so
much.
>> Uh, can I ask how we are for time?
Anyone does any have have any quick
questions or should we close it?
>> Maybe one question if anyone has one
>> or not. Yeah.
>> Simon post
about
somebody who's used
auto research loop in order to optimize
the model for a particular spec of
hardware.
M3.
Have you done anything to optimize for
your hardware setups to to make the
models?
>> Yeah.
>> Match what?
>> What you got?
>> Yeah. I I guess I'm on the more cynical
side with that work. Uh
I
have seen a lot of stuff out there that
is kind of again like cherrypicked and I
think especially if you're using auto
research without really understanding
what's going on you might it might not
even be that you're trying to like hype
this up but you actually believe that
you've made some breakthrough. Um so
like I give you an example. I've seen
like stuff where it is just a one bit
model running and they say like oh look
we have you know Kimmy running from disk
um at and it's not even that good
performance right it's like five tokens
per second or something but you know and
then also you have there's many layers
to it right so like auto research might
make a change that really impacts the
perform like the quality of the model
and you don't realize it because you
think it tells you like oh look it's
running so I think auto research really
powerful tool
But my
my opinion on this is you still need to
follow the scientific method. So you
need to have like a well-reasoned
hypothesis hypothesis you need to then
run experiments to test it and then
you know uh iterate basically. So like
if it's just like oh hey auto research
go off and figure out how to make this
fast it won't work. I think that's a
pretty much a dead end. It's a slot
machine at that point. It's a slot
machine. It's like and it might be
addicted addicting and you might think
like oh wow I've I'm making real
progress here but I think actually the
set of things it can come up with with
slot machine approach is very small and
it will be very sparse as well. Maybe
eventually maybe it will come up with
certain things um you know if enough
people are running it enough compute you
throw at it but it's like brute force
it's basically like brute force approach
um so like I really like auto research
and I'm using it as well like I think
it's a really powerful tool but it needs
to be
used in the context of scientific method
where you actually understand what's
going on.
So yeah, but then specifically on the
disk thing, I just don't think it's
interesting. I think um
obviously the idea of like having memory
hierarchies is is is interesting. That
that's just like a fundamental thing
about um
compute I guess. But um specifically
disk, it's just too slow. There are just
like fundamental constraints there.
You're better off focusing on the memory
problem. Like that's going to be much
more cost effective. Uh, unless you do
some like crazy setup where for for some
reason, you know, stacking a bunch of
SSDs is like way cheaper than um than
using normal memory, right? Which might
maybe that would
>> Yeah, like with memory prices and stuff,
maybe that would become interesting, but
like it's going to be it's not going to
be a MacBook, right? Because MacBook has
one disc and it's not that fast. Um
but like I have seen
some people looking at the problem of
like oh what if we put like 64
SSDs in a box and you know
>> yeah with RAID or something and uh and
then start to use these techniques where
you can be smart about loading in
experts you know you can there's a lot
of research on like predicting which
expert is coming next for example so you
can like optimistically load it and then
you know maybe you're right 90% of the
time, wrong 10% of the time, then you
have to load it again. It's like, you
know, you can do a lot of clever tricks
there, but like for me, like, okay, like
do those tricks, but do it with normal
memory. Don't like why are you why are
you looking at, you know, doing this
with disk?
>> Okay, thank you.
>> In the background, it worked.
>> Oh, okay. We It didn't work. Wait, do
you want to show it then?
>> Yeah. Like so so basically uh we can
show like before and after right can we
show before and after? So so one is like
the MacBook running on its own.
>> Um and you can see like this is a pretty
large prompt. So it's a paper 38 kilob
by or like well two of them. So
>> I'll just do the after first.
>> Okay. Doing the after first. So the
after is using both together. Prefill
decode. So it will do the prefill on the
Spark and the decode on the MacBook.
And uh like one thing to keep in mind
here is this doesn't make sense if
you're doing small prompts. If you're
just saying hello, there's no speed up.
But for like large prompts where the
pre-fill time also goes like
quadratically with the size of the
prompt, right, for most like
architectures of model. So if you're
doing really big prompts, it's going to
actually take a significant amount of
time of the inference. So in this case,
yeah. So there's I don't know this is
like 100 kilobyte prompt or something.
>> Uh yeah it's a lot of
>> is it working?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So basically what it's doing is
it's now you can see the utilization
here. It's like 100% only on the spark.
So it's running the prefilled there and
it's streaming the KV cache over to the
uh MacBook in a way that's like
overlapping. So
>> I think I got a
Oh well.
>> Okay. Wi-Fi, I guess.
>> Okay.
>> Should we try one more?
>> Okay, never mind. You get the idea.
Anyway, uh so yeah, like in this in this
specific example, I think it's about 2x
faster, is it?
>> Uh yes, it's around 2x.
>> Yeah. So you get like on the end to end
time of, you know, doing this whole
thing, the pre-fill and the decode
stage, it's about 2x faster. um
like you know just running on the
MacBook versus running it on both. So
yeah and then again you can imagine like
the next thing here is like okay instead
of a Spark you know what about just
doing this with just a GPU right so you
could do this with a RTX 5090 which is
cheaper and it also has a lot more
memory bandwidth and a lot more compute
so then you can start doing more
interesting things um where you split
parts of the model.
>> Is it working? That's a single node.
>> Okay, that's that's single node.
>> Y
>> Well, I don't know if we need to
>> How long did that take?
>> Uh like uh 7 seconds for one paper.
>> Okay. 7 seconds for one paper with the
just the MacBook and then
We're quite uh just try one more time.
If it doesn't work, it's fine. That's
it.
>> Okay. So now the same paper. Now it
should be running across both. Does it
have to do one more? Okay. Yeah. So, in
that case, 4.8. So, again, this gets
better as you increase size of the
prompt. Um Oh, cool. Okay. I know we're
over, so I'll stop there.
Thank you.